catholic leaders in texas released the
names of almost 300 priests accused of
sexual abuse and they issued a new
apology to victims 14 catholic diocese
in texas yesterday publicly identified
286 priests and others accused of
sexually abusing children over nearly
eight decades now the announcement comes
10 weeks after CBS News first reported
allegations against priests serving in
the Galveston Houston archdiocese a
website that tracks clergy abuse in all
50 states lists more than 5,000 listen
to that 5,000 current or former priests
who have been publicly accused Nicky
batiste has been reporting extensively
on the church sex abuse scandal Nicki
good morning I just I still can't even
get over these numbers they're
astonishing numbers they really are good
morning everyone
father John Keller presided over one of
the largest and most prominent churches
in Houston the Prince of Peace in our
CBS News investigation in November
John Labonte who was one of Keller's
altar boys accused Keller of molesting
him as a child after our story aired
another man similar in age and who
attended the same church as Labonte
reached out to us the first person I see
come up on screen is John Labonte well I
know a John Labonte from Houston and
within a matter of seconds there's a
picture of father John Keller what is
going through your mind at that point
I've never been struck by lightning but
I think that's about as close as you get
mark Quinn was watching our CBS news
investigation last year right here where
it says you know acted very
inappropriate when John Labonte told us
father Keller molested him as a child
even though in 2002 the church said it
wasn't sexual abuse
if you
in November we took Labonte's
allegations to Cardinal Daniel DiNardo
who's in charge of the Houston
archdiocese and president of the US
Conference of Catholic Bishops seeing
that moment on television disgusted Marc
Quinn he then took his allegations to
the church all I kept saying was holy
blank
there's my boogey man Quinn says father
Keller touched him inappropriately when
he was eight years old now 50 he says he
kept his nightmare a secret all his life
I just felt like how dare you side with
the pedophile over the parishioners and
yet this has been the Catholic Church's
mo time after time but then the church
and Cardinal DiNardo took Quinn by
surprise they included father John
Keller's name on their just release list
of credibly accused priests and removed
him from active ministry Cardinal
DiNardo also apologized to victims I did
not ignore or neglect any any one priest
that was brought to my attention some
would say you may move too slowly but I
recall once something came to my
attention I moved on it father John
Keller was probably not going to be on
the list and now he is likely because of
you coming forward his name being on
that list means a great deal to me you
just don't get to get off that easy
John Labonte hopes the church will now
reopen his case what are you feeling in
this moment I do have some relief in
knowing that through telling my story
that others might be protected we
reached out to the Prince of Peace and
John Keller but they say they have no
comment
Cardinal DiNardo is expected to meet
with Pope Francis in Rome next month
during a global bishops meeting to
address the sex abuse crisis and the
Catholic Church and I will tell you so
many survivors and victims have said
they're frustrated by Pope Francis as
lack of action so no doubt they'll be
watching really closely there has been a
lack of action by the Vatican but I like
the point there that by one person
speaking out and
allows others stories to come out as
well and this will not change until all
of those stories are told until there is
full accountability yes and I think
finally some relief for those coming
forward that they're being heard and
being believed and important that names
are added to this list but this list
appears to be endless 5,000 unbelievable
astonishing the whole team has done a
great job great reporting